what's your go-to karaoke song euni
wonder usually go if I'm going a little
but more exciting I like signed sealed
delivered or I'll go superstition or or
movie on reggae woman yeah but then I'm
feeling I'm trying to make the ladies
you know trying to impress somebody then
I'll go my fairy or more because that's
just a great song just a little slow
wait wait that I love Stevie Wonder but
not many people want to go where Stevie
Wonder is gone oh yeah it's it's so much
fun
I what's the point of doing it if you're
not going to go all out you know
beautiful do not carry out these er boys
can crack and you cares because you're
singing to 12 people in a bar so fun how
are the pirates doing this year we're
doing pretty good you know we had a
really really really good start
super hot out of the gate and then we
were you know really bad for a while
there and we're evening things out but I
think that you know our team were very
we're super young really unexpected
staff and and you know we're going
through some growing pains and stuff but
it's it's super fun we're all really
close and I think that what was what's
good about our season is that since we
did so well at the beginning going to a
really tough stretch like we did we're
still you know we're still afloat we're
only a you know six seven games back
first place and you know we had a tough
division obviously so it's it's a good
place to be I think right now he's
Steven Broughton he sang the
star-spangled banner' the Pirates
left-hander joining us Dan Patrick show
all right we have signed sealed
delivered or my Sharia or more so which
one do you uh you want to hear my theory
and lore for sure all right I'll let you
sing along with it let's see a little
karaoke here right so here's Steve the
great Stevie Wonder and the good Steven
brought hey nice okay there we go
and in three two one here we
[Music]
were you you know what Stephen won't you
just sing it okay do I have to thing
more yeah yeah yeah just just give me
hard
give me a corner yeah in a cafe
sometimes on a crowded Street Oh near
you but you never notice me where are
you right now
I'm sitting in my house okay so you're
not like an apartment building where
somebody's gonna say Stephen stop it the
construction workers that are working on
the house next to mine I think they've
heard me sing a little bit so I think
they're you stood at this point for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]